[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben in diesem video zeige
ich euch die ihr diese zweistöckige
verlobungs torte schritt für schritt
nach machen könnt
[Musik]
ich habe zwei tage bevor die torte
angeschnitten wurde schon mal die
italienische buttercreme hergestellt
dafür habe ich 360 gramm eine saubere
fettfreie schüssel gegeben
außerdem benötigen wir noch eine prise
salz 550 gramm zucker und 1000 gramm
weiche butter
[Musik]
die
zu dem eiweiss kommen dann noch salz und
zucker eiweiß zuckermasse beatles über
einem wasserbad erhitzt und zwar auf
über 70 grad
dann habt ihr die garantie dass mögliche
salmonellen absterben und ihr könnt die
roche-aktien ohne bedenken genießen
ganz wichtig ist hierbei dass wir die
masse ständig umrührt nie aus den augen
lassen wenn ihr zwei minuten lang mal
mich rührt dann wird auf dem weiß
natürlich ruhe
bei 70 grad lasse ich das ganze dann in
einen mixer aufschlagen das könnt ihr
euch machen während die masse noch heiß
ist das gar kein problem
anschließend wissen will sie allerdings
erkalten lassen bevor wir die butter
reintun ich mache das immer so also
gerade bei einer großen menge an butter
kleben las ich dann die db masse
wirklich eine stunde lang stehen oder
sogar noch länger damit komplett
ausgekühlt wenn ihr das nicht macht und
die butter im lauwarmen zustand dann
noch rein dann könnt ihr quasi die ganze
14 wegwerfen also dann geht doch einfach
nicht
der nächste schritt ist dass wir die
butter in vier bis fünf schritten zu bw
machte geben und gut unterrühren
[Musik]
es kann sein dass die butter kleben dann
einen moment lang glücklich aussieht ich
weiß nicht ob man sich ein video gut
erkennen
aber dann dürft ihr nicht verzweifeln
einfach weiter mit so lange bis ihnen
schöne geschmeidige machte erhalten und
so habe ich die buttercreme mit
frischhaltefolie abgedeckt und bis zum
nächsten tag im kühlschrank gelagert
für die zubereitung der show wurden
benötigen wir die eier 180 gramm zucker
200 gramm lauwarme milch 200 gramm
sonnenblumen oder rapsöl und an
trockenen zutaten 250 gramm mehl 100
gramm cacau 50 gramm stärke und eine
packung backpulver
als erstes werden die eier mit dem
zucker in der küchenmaschine zirka vier
minuten meint er mich geschlagen
[Musik]
wenn die eier zucker masse dann hält
ewig ist kommen noch die füssing zur
kabine hinein also öl und milch und
werden kurz und wird
[Musik]
zum schluss kommen dort die trockenen
zutaten hinein hier ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir die siebt damit auch keine
klümpchen im team sind und dass wir dann
auch noch mal ganz kurz untergerührt bis
ich alles verbunden hat
[Musik]
ich habe den schoko boden dem ich euch
gerade gezeigt habe insgesamt zwei mal
gebacken
es ist wichtig dass sie das zweimal
einzelnen back to nicht einmal zusammen
weil der sonst kaum chance hoch bewerben
und dann mit links der ganze grüßen
[Musik]
den teig fühle ich dann in meinen
backwaren den habe ich auf 26 zentimeter
eingestellt der wird dann bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze beträgt 35 minuten
bewachten für das land geld benötigen
wir den saft aus acht zitronen und auch
die schale ins bio zitronen sind
außerdem unsere übrig gebliebenen zehn
gelbe vier esslöffel butter 30 gramm
stärke und 500 gramm zucker
die zubereitung ist er sehr einfach dazu
müsst ihr nur alle zutaten in einen topf
geben und gut miteinander verrühren
die masse kommt dann auf den herd wird
ein mal aufgekocht dadurch liegt das
ganze ein wirt einmal durch einen brief
gestrichen damit keine klümpchen da sind
unternehmen gehört auch schon fertig ist
muss nur noch auf touren
dadurch dass wir suchen albrich haben
von der butter kleben habe ich hier sehr
viel lernen kürze breite die haben dafür
später noch als brotaufstrich verwendet
aber wir benötigen letztendlich nur zwei
etwa höhe während das seven card im
tiefkühlschrank herunterkühlt kümmere
ich mich um die schokocreme auf den
gegebenen zutaten wurde 1750 gramm
butter kleben
davon habe ich mir 900 gramm in eine
separate schüssel getan gäbe da noch
zwei esslöffel nutella hinzu und vermixt
aufeinander
somit ist die schoko mutter kind für die
untere etage auch schon fertig und
weiter geht's mit der zitronen
buttercreme dafür werden zwei esslöffel
weiche butter und vier esslöffel welt
miteinander vernetzt und zwar eine
minute lang deshalb geht das lernen
körper muss für diesen schritt unbedingt
abgekühlt sein
von meiner ursprünglichen butter gehen
habe ich mir viel 700 gramm in eine
schütze gefahr gebe dann die lemon creme
dazu unterwegs für das miteinander und
ich habe bewusst 150 gramm butter kind
übrig gelassen für den fall der fälle
falls es bei der schoko buttercreme oder
zitronen butter kleben nicht mehr
ausreichen sollte die erste etage wird
jetzt gestapelt ich habe euch jetzt
nicht gezeigt wie ich die besten
hersteller dafür eben ein separates
video für euch in den vorwochen
verwinkelt zwischen meinem sport und dem
ersten tortenboden habe ich etwas butter
kinder geben damit das ganze etwas
fester wird nicht verrutscht dann
aromatisiert das noch mit unseren
körpern zubereitet haben darüber kommt
dann eine schicht von letzte thronen
buttercreme und der nächste torfboden
die obere torte hatte übrigens um 20
zentimeter durchmesser
ich schreibe euch die mengenangaben auf
jeden fall in die infobox die
zubereitung seht ihr dann in den
separaten video
nachdem alle vier tortenböden gefüllt
und gestrichen wurden
geht noch mal der ganze kuchen dünnen
mit buttercreme aufnahmen verstrichen
[Musik]
die torte kommt dann zum kühlen für 20
minuten in den kühlschrank und solange
geht es weiter mit dem unteren teil der
torte auch hier wird das skateboard
wieder mit etwas butter kleben
bestrichen
dann kommt der erdboden drauf dass
getränke ich diesmal mit karamell sirup
möchte ich mit etwas milch verdient habe
[Musik]
anschließend mit der schoko pro takt
befüllen und so weiter machen sind alle
vier tortenböden gefüllt sind
[Musik]
frische tortenböden sind immer etwas
schwieriger durchzuschneiden und der
zeit habe ich hier das stück das er
gerade abgefallen ist nochmal mit
buttercreme befestigt
[Musik]
hier wird auch wieder dünn mit butter
themen eingestrichen und dann gebt ihr
das ganze bis zum 25
[Musik]
jede torten ist zweimal mit der butter
bestrichen werden die erste schicht
dient nur zur bindung und die zweite
schicht wird dann schön glatt und gerade
gemacht damit es eine gute unterlage von
vonlanthen
[Musik]
ich hatte ja geraten ca 150 gramm butter
sind übrig zu lassen für den fall der
fälle falls bei einer der butter kings
etwas erreichen wollte und ich habe in
meinem fall in die nutella butter kleben
gestiegen anschließend hat seinen
perfect gereicht am besten die torten
jetzt noch mal gut durchführen lassen
eine halbe stunde lang und dann kann
auch schon der von land ausgeräumt
werden am einfachsten geht das ganze auf
becker stärker ausgerollt ich habe mein
fondant hellrosa eingefärbt
[Musik]
dann wird der verband auf die torte
gegeben als erstes die oberfläche mit
dem von ganz glatt streichen und danach
vorsichtig an den seiten herunter
arbeiten
den überschuss schneide ich da mit
meinem afrikanische ab
[Musik]
nach dem gleichen prinzip habe ich die
untere torte mit weißem von lack drei
bekleidet anschließend habe ich sie mit
silbernen lebensmittelfarbe einstrichen
ich werde euch nochmal die genaue
bezeichnung in die infobox schreiben und
die obere rose eine torte habe ich mit
so einem muster versehen
[Musik]
anschließend habe ich mir aufreißen von
dateien namens mädchen ausgestochen
mit hilfe eines buchstaben ausstieg habe
ich dann noch die namen aus romanen
fondant aufgestochen und geben sie dann
auf der fernstrecke
[Musik]
zuerst habe ich die buchstaben nur
locker drauf gelegt und zu schauen ob da
noch platz und anschließend mit
superkleber bis deftig superkleber
selber herstellen können das schreibe
ich euch in die infobox
[Musik]
bis staffeln der torte habe ich mir
etwas butter blick auf die tortenplatte
gegeben damit das als kleber fungiert
habe dann die silberne torte darauf
gegeben und 100 euch nicht dass auf der
oberfläche nicht ganz ausgemacht ist
denn das sieht man hier sowieso nicht
werden
für den torten abschluss habe ich hier
noch etwas klebeband zurecht geschnitten
und mit einer lade hinter fixiert
damit die torte gestartet werden kann
müssen wir ein paar stückchen einbauen
in diesem fall habe ich habe die
strohhalme genommen bzw
diese dicken katrina strohhalme die
funktionieren immer ganz gut
ein habe ich in die torte gesteckt und
dann an der oberfläche abgeschnitten
die anderen strohhalme habe ich dann auf
die gleichen länge zurecht geschnitten
insgesamt waren das stück
[Musik]
an
durch die strohhalme wie die torte
stabil genug und jetzt kann euch nicht
passieren was die obere dorthin die
untere einsacken darüber gebe ich wieder
etwas butter gehen und gäbe dann die
zweite etage darauf
[Musik]
ende
auch hier gebe ich wieder ein bändchen
drumherum und verschiedene patienten mit
einer lade
[Musik]
anschließend gebe ich das
namensschildchen mithilfe vom zucker
kleber auf die untere etage
da ich für diese torte echte rosen
verwendet habe durften die mit dem
kuchen nicht im bogen und kommen und
deshalb habe ich dafür bestimmte toben
reingetan diesen extras deutsche torten
gedacht es empfiehlt sich auf jeden fall
vorher mit einer langen loch thüle
medlock vorzubereiten und dann die
proben hineinzustecken
und falls die torte bei euch noch länger
stehenbleibt dann würde ich da auch
etwas gleichen einführen
zum fixieren der rosenblätter könnt ihr
auch noch diese stecknadeln verwenden
merkt euch einfach wie viele ihr benutzt
haben die könnt ihr weiter geben ich
habe fünf stück genutzt bitte achtet
darauf dass sie raus nimmt bevor das
angeschnitten hier und dann ist die
torte auch schon fertig solche torten
herzustellen ist natürlich immer etwas
stressiger und deshalb seht ihr auch da
auf meinem tisch die unordnung es tut
mir auch sehr leid aber ich wollte
trotzdem so gerne mit film vielleicht
ist es ja eine anregung für eure nächste
torte die torte ist sowohl optisch als
auch geschmacklich sehr gut angekommen
und falls das video bei euch auch gut
eine com ist dann freue ich mich sehr
über einen daumen hoch und über euer abo
bis zum nächsten mal auf die spitze
[Musik]